Oh
[Music]
so let's talk about what life is
you know Buckminster Fuller said that
life is anti-entropic see in the
universe you have the second law of
thermodynamics you have entropy
everywhere entropy is breaking
everything into its simpler constituents
entropy is the playing out of process
breaking things down but then you have
this thing called life in this
Goldilocks zone this phenomenon of life
life emerges itself organizes it's
almost like life resides in a part of
the universe that is self-organizing
towards complexity its complexity that
bootstraps on its own complexity
single-celled organisms emerge in the
biochemistry of a planet like the earth
that linked lives in the Goldilocks zone
and these single-celled organisms clump
together into multicellular organisms
these multicellular organisms eventually
become primates these primates then get
caught in self-awareness they start to
self perceive then these primates start
to imagine future possibilities that I
start planning a mind emerges a fear or
mind turns into a tool as Kevin Kelley
says they can then think with purpose
and deliberation then we spill over the
creations of our minds into tools and
then we engage in feedback loops with
those tools to further extend our
creative possibilities it's fascinating
because it seems there's visit there's a
there's a process of sort of a
self-organization of emerges that's
happening here it's like these things
are coming together and they're creating
transcendent effects they're exhibiting
transcendent effects you know Minds
brains these things seem to be greater
than the sum of their parts it's when
you have higher-level order from
lower-level organization this this
emergence you know when birds enter
swarms there's no leader there's nobody
telling all the other birds how to get
into these formations but it seems to be
self-organizing and we know that we are
made of atoms those atoms turn into
clump together into cells the cells
clump together into or
and those organs have come together in
to us and then we create tools and we
wire each other mind to mind
communication we create a guy a global
brain this global brain itself part of
the biological global grid nervous
system of nature and those two things
breathing thinking the thinking stratum
of the universe the universe wakes up
[Music]
you